So in the spring if you're thinking about
testing your soil in the garden you have a
couple of options.
One is to collect a soil sample and send it
into the lab for analysis, and the second
is to buy one of these simple kits that allows
you to analyze your soil at home and get some
general recommendations for either adding
fertilizer or adjusting your soil pH.
They are all based on adding soil and water
to a tube and then adding a reagent, and then
matching the color in the tube to the color
on a card.
So they're a simple test and will give us
some general information about the status
of our soil.
Once you've put the soil in and the reagent
and the water, and followed the instructions,
you will match the color to one of the color
cards.
So for the pH test you'll match it to the
pH card, phosphorous, nitrogen and potassium.
It's a pretty simple kit, it's putting the
reagents in the water and the soil into the
tube and matching the color.
So these kits are all available generally
for under $30 at most garden stores or you
can order them online.
There are also other kits available.
These results won't be as precise as sending
them into the lab for analysis, but for most
of us in the garden it will get us close enough
and it will help us determine how much fertilizer
we might need to add or if we need to adjust
our pH.
With the University of Wyoming Extension,
I'm Caitlin Youngquist and you're watching
From the Ground Up.